[Musique]
allez vous chantez chez vous
aussi à toi non ce n'était pas le Radeau
de la Méduse ce bateau on se le dis au
fond des Pors dis au fond des pororts
il naviguait en perpénard sur la Grand
mare des canards et s'appelait les
copains d'abord les copains
d'abord fluctu toigiture c'était pas de
la littérature non des plais au jeteur
de sort au jeteur de
sort son cap son capitaine et ses
matelots n'étent pas des enfants de
salon mais des amis franco de port des
copains d'abord c'est néta pas des amis
de luxe des petits castard et polxe des
gens de Sodom et Gomorre Sodom et
gomor c'était pas des amis choisis par
Montaigne et la boésie sur le ventre il
se tapaient fort les copains d'abord à
toi c'est bastien maintenant hein
c'était pas des anges non plus
l'Évangile il l'avait pas lu mais il se
met toute voile dehors toute voile
dehors Jean-Pierre Paul
c'était leur se Litan leur crédau leur
confit au copain
d'abord
aureou c'est l'amitié qui prenait le car
c'est elle qui leur montrait le Nord
leur montrait le nord et quand ils étai
en
[Musique]
déess souvent le lapin quand l'unautre
manquit àord ce qu'il
était oui mais jamais grand jamais son
trou dans l'au se referma 100s après
coquin de sort il manquait
encore des bateau j'eni pris beaucoup
mais le se qui est
ten
jamaord oh la pierre c'est
jolieard sur la grande
a les copains d'abord les copains
[Musique]
d'abord des bateau écr beau coup
mais leû
[Musique]
du canard il s'appelent les copains
d'abord les copains
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'abord